this is an extremely brief history of
Super Bowl commercials with Hank green
in 1967 the first ever Super Bowl alerta
since that 1967 broadcast the Super Bowl
has become America's most watched yearly
event and advertising dollars have
skyrocketed along with that skyrocketing
Super Bowl advertisers had that justify
the Uni wanted if they were spending and
the Super Bowl advertisements have
become a spectacle in and of themselves
with nerds like myself and housewives
across the nation proclaiming that they
watched the Super Bowl just for the ads
and when people are enjoying the
advertisements more than they're
enjoying the actual program we have
reached a kind of cultural nexus that I
believe is probably worth studying in
1973 the first ever super high-profile
Super Bowl ad was aired it featured the
sexy sting and vixen Farrah Fawcett
spreading NOx even cream all over Super
Bowl quarterback John names face and it
was hot and set the bar high for rather
inappropriate Super Bowl advertisements
that later
GoDaddy would incinerate in 1980 Mean
Joe Greene tossed his game-worn Jersey
to a young boy in return for a Coca Cola
this advertisement became such a
touching social phenomenon that didn't
Leiter became the only advertisement
ever to have a full-length movie based
upon it in the actual 1984 Apple Channel
George Orwell's 1984 and somehow tried
to make the case that Ibn was Big
Brother which looking back doesn't
really make sense nonetheless it raised
the bar for Super Bowl advertisements
about two miles I think the word we're
looking for here is epic in 1985 Apple
went from epic to epic fail with an
advertisement that portrayed IBM users
as lemmings blindly walking to their
deaths turns out that one didn't when
the mini fans and was instrumental in
getting Steve Jobs fired from his job in
1989 Budweiser start up the bud Bowl
which was just like a miniature beer
based Super Bowl I remember as a kid
really liking the bud Bowl which makes
me question whether it was a good
marketing strategy for an alcoholic
beverage but moving on in 1997 zombie
Fred Astaire we were assuming because he
was dead did it dance with a Dirt Devil
vacuum cleaner in the year 2000 more
than a dozen dot-com companies blew
their funding paying more than two
million dollars for 30-second spots most
of those companies no longer exist
including epidemic com a company that
paid you to email your friends
advertisements the bankruptcy of this
company is one of the primary reasons
that I believe deep down in my heart
that people are not jerks last year in
2009 the first ever 3d television
commercials debuted at the Superbowl
with advertising agencies giving away
three D glass
to individuals and passing them out of
bars across the country and this year in
2010 for the first time in almost 40
years the cost of a Super Bowl
advertisement is dropping this reflects
the fundamental weakening of television
in the rise of YouTube uh possibly not
but you can use YouTube to help decide
which Super Bowl advertisements were the
best of 2010 all you got to do is click
here and choose your favorites this has
been an extremely brief history of Super
Bowl commercials with Hank green